a massacre in a quiet community
celebrating Lunar New Year 10 people
five men and five women were killed when
a gunman entered the star Ballroom in
Monterey Park California Saturday
evening 10 others were wounded some
critically one of the County's most
heinous cases
hours after the killings police in
Torrance 48 kilometers Southwest of the
crime scene surrounded a white van
believed to be linked to the shooting as
officers closed in a single shot was
fired from inside the vehicle at 12 52
PM our Sheriff's SWAT team approached
and cleared the van and determined the
suspect sustained a self-inflicted
gunshot wound
and was pronounced dead at the scene
investigators conducted a search of the
vehicle and determined the mail inside
the van was the mass shooting suspect
the gunman was who can Tran a 72 year
old man of Asian descent police said he
had several Firearms including a
semi-automatic machine pistol police
have not disclosed a motive we want to
know we want to know how something like
this something this awful can happen
congresswoman Judy Chu represents the
area there are also other rumors about
this being a dispute
by a husband who caught his wife dancing
there police say shortly after the
Monterey Park shooting there was a
related incident at another nearby dance
studio who can Tran entered the studio
with a gun but was disarmed by patrons
he was disarmed by two community members
who I consider to be heroes because they
say saved lives this could have been
much worse people in Monterey Park a
city of sixty one thousand whose
residents are predominantly
Asian-American we're stunned by the
violence I was shocked I was because the
Barham dancing Studios where I go
dancing on Monday evenings with friends
and I was hit close to me you know my
kids were afraid to go to sleep last
night because they were afraid the
shooter might break the windows and come
in or something I had to tell them no no
it's okay you know Comfort them to go to
sleep the killings came at the Lunar New
Year normally a joyous family oriented
Festival Monterey Park now joins a long
list of U.S towns and cities scarred by
deadly gun violence what should have
been a time of Celebration is now a time
of mourning in a community that may be
changed forever
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Monterey Park
California